mine that's a good question the answer
to start off with what was going on in
your mind Wesley were you thinking that
you might have chances to win that game
at any point or did you just sing and
play for a draw no I was just playing
chess uh playing chess yeah no but
actually I thought the winning move on
move 40 like I was I had 10 minutes and
I totally saw it you did say queen C7
yeah I mean I was gonna play it but I
thought Wendy four wins too I just
forget that his King can advance all the
way to F4 if I played the big bitty but
at the same time it's not like I was
winning the entire game and he had a
chance yeah he played a very good
defensive game up to that point because
probably
first of all after King G1
F4 which I just missed and then I just
did the queen of seven still win or
Queen F7 I thought rook ge5 and I'm
pinned and if not so easy not so easy
yeah but you have to but I miss queen F4
I mean I saw the pin but also after
Queen C7 after G3
Queen F7 Rook G5 King G7 I forgot that
after seven I have Knight G4
should have played it but this
tournament I missed so many chances so
just part of life but at the same time
happy that uh because apparently I made
some mistakes a couple mistakes in the
game but he was it seems like he was
better at one point but it was indeed
very very difficult this moment he could
have played this move Rook to E7 I'm not
even sure if the years
yeah yeah yeah it's really crazy because
um
the game was so complex
and uh made a couple Miss I think we
both made a couple of mistakes here and
there but um
um no it's not so easy with limited time
it's been very very difficult to get a
victory in this tournament especially
against Hikaru it's always difficult to
get a victory what are you going to do
differently to try to get that result
tomorrow
[Music]
well try to
not mess up try to get Advantage you
know and
try to try to play well
I mean today had a big chance for one
move
but uh
yeah at the same time he had like
millions of throws before that so it's
nothing
it's just you know I'm just happy to
still being determined but the car was
very good player I'm surprised he's
doing so well even though he spends 24 7
streaming
yeah I would if I was him I wouldn't be
able to play this well and create so
much content well lastly you got to know
Hikaru so personally in this tournament
as well you've played already a very
long match against him what do you feel
his strengths weaknesses are can you
describe Hikaru as a player
well he's been playing really well over
the last
year over the almost over the last two
years uh
he's
he's doing so well like in the Grand
Prix also some rapid St Louis rapid and
Blitz also all the classical tournaments
that he played in uh well he's very good
he's very well prepared in the opening
first of all he has his second long time
second grace little job but how does he
do it because you just mentioned he
streams 24 7. how does he still maintain
that preparation yeah I mean
obviously giant Thurman I guess he
memorized us a lot you know he prepares
with a super computer with the second
you know and then before the tournament
I think he works on his General Chester
uh for sure you know he thought about
puzzles I guess he looks at games too
but you gotta ask him for more compared
absolutely but I mean in speed chess
he's uh definitely in top two or tapped
in the world yeah sir Jovi yeah a quick
question for you Wesley first of all I
thought it was a great game seriously uh
oh uh we really really enjoyed
commentating the game I just wanted to
ask you your opinion about the head
shaking at the very end did you
interpret that as
as uh Hikaru
blundering the game to a loss or
blundering the game to a draw when he
saw him shaking his head was he
indicating to you that he had given up
he'd let the victory slip by or
yeah he probably didn't see the the in
the beginning like this King Jitter King
F4 King E5
because uh I bet he's talking H3 Queen
D7 and
black wings
but um
he probably thought he was losing at one
at some point
um
and he had very little time he had three
minutes
and well I played the current many years
I as I said before when he's shaking his
head that means you're in very big
terrible actually it's the opposite when
he's shaking his head then
you know that's when he starts looking
for most chances like in the rapid in
the first rapid game he started shaking
his head also but then he was playing
for a win then he found all the best
moves so is this Civic no he's taking
his help no I totally deceiving when
he's shaking his head you know that he's
looking for all the tricks
but you know it is what it is I mean I
don't really
I think it's my fault for not playing
Queen season playing 24 to too quickly
but um
I was also getting very tired you know
I'm the only player who didn't have a
rest day here so it's not so easy to
play four or five hours
every single day and then you also have
to prepare a little bit so that's why I
have to be in good physical shape we'll
let you get your rest now Wesley uh
we'll look forward to the game tomorrow
and again I think it was a great game
awesome very happy birthday to you yeah
hey thank you thank you I'm just looking
for a lot of serious cash okay
serious cash birthday presents
he only takes cash in a briefcase you
don't want cakes or cupcakes huh
cupcakes I got the cupcakes covered with
the cash serious serious cash that's the
briefcase at the door Wesley thank you
Wesley good luck to borrow and thank you
Esther nice uh what a super finals